dans les ivelines un collectif de 98
élus municipaux d'opposition vient de se
créer issu d'une quarantaine de communes
des ivelines et de tout parti politique
de gauche comme de droite leur objectif
est pourtant le même réveiller la
démocratie locale comme beaucoup de mes
concitoyens j'avais le sentiment que Ben
la démocratie au niveau local
fonctionnait bien je me suis très
rapidement rendu compte dans le cadre de
ce mandat que finalement bah la
démocratie est également en panne au
niveau local la démocratie effectivement
locale n'est pas chos aisé dans de
nombreuses communes moi j'ai eu à me
battre pendant 2 ans juste pour faire
reconnaître un simple droit d'expression
puisque notre notre Maire nous déigniait
le la possibilité de nous exprimer à sa
convenance le problème n'est pas là mais
sur la page officielle Facebook de la
mairie alors qu'effectivement c'est
inscrit dans les dans les textes pour
avoir connaissance des documents et pour
pouvoir tout simplement essayer de
comprendre ce qui est prévu dans les
projets de la majorité c'est très
compliqué et on a du coup aucun espace
d'expression on n pas des on a que 500
caractères par exemple dans le bulletin
trimestriel mais on n' pas accès à la
page Facebook on n pas d'autres moments
d'expression et même en conseil c'est
très compliqué de de pouvoir s'exprimer
face à ce constat ils ont émis une
quinzaine de propositions comme la
création d'un observatoire national de
la démocratie locale ou une révision de
la prime majoritaire la prime
majoritaire c'est une aberration
démocratique c'est-à-dire que elle est
aujourd'hui à 50 % ça veut dire que si
vous arrivez en tête vous récupérez déjà
50 % des sièges euh au niveau au niveau
du conseil municipal ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que dans une ville par
exemple où il y a il y a eu 32 voix
d'écart il y a 23 voix pour la 23 sièges
pardon pour la majorité et et 7 pour
l'opposition fin septembre ces
propositions ont été présentées au
président du Sénat Gérard Larché ce
dernier s'est montré attentif sur
certains points d'ici un mois les élus
d'opposition souhaitent lancer leur
propre baromètre de la démocratie locale
les en fonction des résultats le
collectif demandera une entrevue avec le
préfet des yelin